Nói Ní Can Vietnam và trường lại học phát phoà thành phố Chuyên Kí Két hợp tác chính lực tòan dịn đám đam
về phát triển công nghệ và trên lực công nghệ.
Mời đau tròan trình này là dự án nghiên cứu và phát triển bố bất hiện người ULGG một trong
chính tháng nghiên cứu và phát triển.
Mời nghiên cứu xin của khoa khoa khoa và ký thuật máy tính sẽ trực tiếp tham gia lập trình và phát triển
các khá năng bất hàng tức trụ và thá tác thương hành trên gồm bố ULGG một.
Nếu đến bất khá phát triển năng lực giúp đồ bất trong một trường sản xuất tế, đây là bất đi nhằm kết nối năng lực nghiên cứu
của nhà trường với những bài toán công nghệ từ tiến từ hơi đi kèn Việt Nam.
Quà đó, cùng phát triển các giải phát có khá năng lực giúp trong thực tế, phùa bịch hướng phát triển phoà
công nghệ đồ mới sáng tạo phát triển đổi số cúch ra các tình tình tình nghĩ quyết năm mới.
Thông qua kế mắt tay chỉ lực này, hay bên khi vọng mộn hình kết nối vệnh vững dựng giữ,
đã tạo vào lực giúp công nghệ và từ tiến.